what's good okay suicide yeah so where'd
you grow up you say where'd you grow up
I blow up man I'm on boniato by raising
hell about raising five tools that's
right
born in a blah blah phrase in LA and
would agree with you uh-huh
I've always heard the 14 5 de lluvia
it's 14 yeah
my mom said up oh now I'm positive the
life sentence Mary died our prisoner
Electra age - I used to never age - he
died each other
I got 19 so far it's only twice a year
did your mom she's there she's good I
mean she was she's a crackhead I'm
saying I feel good not all go to church
to change one so the gang was a good
natural law that's family
holy we'll be inside that and prison
time you're done in prison that 15 years
rule
wait
Robbie sure like their what age is that
like 18 did you finish high school
I did agree never left a Conchie shower
so I couldn't finish
my cheesy dough okay
Prison TV yeah I did that say one day
[Music]
because everyone in your situations
musicians would
you
my mom yeah oh yeah uh-huh
I love my mom
I wish she did Louise bought me the
looming always bought me know man right
ha you know especially going up north
believes it you feel me
yeah no still our lives they've been
dying early yeah you see some crazy
stuff in the game right there anything
for us friends
secretly Stephanie other games place up
at the Chloe local the world scream
don't say you love your game you crazy
language is that being recognized
craziness yeah that's what you
recognized it would personality traits
you think a person needs to see my old
man just be real bu bu absolutely do you
nothing go fate and shrimp attendees my
yells be able to get more you get more
your step you live nobody's you don't
get caught up they want me like their
support support
the movie [ __ ] I'm saying now invite
that bust Bob Russell told about us
battle take it home so the guy on me
just be a survive we don't survive you
get run over
there's my you kind of have against
anybody pull these anybody be run over
you know so I that means I suppose when
I treated the whole turn in the prison I
ask you now one day yeah there's not one
day
19:01 dance when I hear also it balls
when he's lost with balls and gates
chain chain gang like a prison still
exists just different this the words the
world aside wearable so it is
I think Gosar if you do it inside you
know we look up the god screams oh god
that not it's in the closet
[Music]
if you were
you feel safer being out in prison
didn't she that's the question the
question was if I ate it with
you say one thing prison my question yet
it's Bob I laugh at that let's say
prison you know what the sky
wake up tie your shoes you don't you I
do right here in with this bag close
ones be dangerous ones I mean people see
I said what I'm saying well Dan isn't in
criminal so yes so highly respected good
good Buddhist or you're not up on some
just don't like you see
it was nice
[Music]
is it was business here because it's not
a term which is going for my time 33 but
I didn't I did that long time like a
year here to join in between we said
between 14 is obeying God's honest truth
a price like three years old streets
nobody they not
hey kiddo I love to pop up value what
did what do you see for yourself
that's right now though yeah but that's
my self-organizing truth that it's hard
slow down charlie I mean buffet me like
I'm gonna show now my I myself seen a
little bit but as in gentleness from
there as an understanding of society
given given given like the chance to
help you I just wanna see that because
I'm sorry see that I go to church
tonight like I wanna stab people or so
last time you got me awesome we should
have I mean you know how come they
listen
it's hard to listen and try to follow
what distances December church Sunday
and coming out full-time because you
know that you can't jingle the streets
on my home god save me when do when
she's going down
where you think that the streets get
local
you started again
like that
said that - yeah why not be somebody
done
so if you'd called out to do whatever
you need to do but angle you're there
that most I think it's done
and um means over that was nice it has
amazing
loving given people like no you know
vices and you feel me like I know
anything about you flag right now or
like them boys and fly a bit a bit a
fool to Oh fry them after that I didn't
mean well yeah I shall activist in just
I still my family but still my nephews
in know me ladies so my garlic that I
live or teaching the right way round
wooden who will I will you stay here for
as in don't gang [ __ ] no I mean plus
like things me not I'm saying
francelina me I look at the cumulative
like magazine what could each other you
me large best man how it was artist
takes it back well I don't chase it
I understand that what they doing now is
like wise to do so I be a hypocrite
saying I don't wrong
I was in the same [ __ ] no saying how I
had it no father so like I can tell you
Genesis a yo if you're doing the other
anyway experience I mean learning is
about spirits right that's something you
learn especially if you like you had no
real hard
father Phil in life no forgiving I say
and intimidation and judges because
being the chance I think that chance
no say okay judge me I need a change I
need a chance to have a father figure
that son was right or wrong I didn't
so how you gonna judge me say I'm well
watch my life yeah be people didn't
Chris this day say that I was a young
boy no no leadership so you see that
even after Trevor get me wrong I enjoy
saying it but I wouldn't say that that's
all I would say that I'd rather change
me I'll be better in society
how's it gonna cater a chance
for my school game John
come home get in John how you have a
chance that goes who right side of your
chance